hey guys Pete here another episode of
Twin Peaks the return has come and gone
and this will be my recap and review for
twenty peak season three episode or part
five now if you haven't watched part
five yet then you will want to stop
watching here because this is a spoiler
alert it will spoil everything you're
not familiar with my recap and reviews
I'm going to do a seam by seam I'm going
to talk about all the different things
that happen but if you want to skip that
there will be a timestamp link right in
this description below the video so you
can just skip ahead and join the
discussion all right here we go we start
off in Las Vegas where we catch up with
the two would-be Dougy assassins they're
waiting and watching Dougie's car at
Rancho Rosa and reporting to a new
character who appears to be in charge of
hiring them and making sure the job gets
done she looks a little skittish and has
definitely upset that they hadn't killed
dougie yet she's in an indiscriminate
office where she pulls out of blackberry
she has the tapes looking stressed but
eventually punches the word argent and
the number two into the keypad it looked
like her finger was hovering over the
minus sign but I honestly couldn't tell
if she sent a message or not see you cut
to what looks like an electronic device
sitting in a wooden bowl it has two red
lights on it they blink but again not
sure if this was directly connected to
what the woman was doing with the
BlackBerry next we get a gruesome shot
of the autopsy of the headless John Doe
that was found in Ruth Davenport's bed
we find out that the cause of death was
the beheading itself and that the victim
hadn't eaten food for days the medical
examiner did find Dougie's wedding ring
in the deceased stomach we know it is
because it's inscribed to dougie was
love Janie
II II and with that the plot thickens I
would say evil coupe is biding his time
and what it looks like some sort of
administrative segregation inside the
federal prisons in South Dakota
not necessarily solitary confinement for
doing something wrong since we arrived
there but more likely protective custody
meaning that he is an FBI agent anyway
he's alone instead of with the other
prisoners lying on the bed he says now
food comes before the icon you know
before the officer actually appears so
he was in tune with what the you know
schedule is or whatever when the food is
delivered he goes to wash up in the you
know a sink there in his cell there's a
small mirror above it and I don't know
about you guys but I was on the edge of
my seat waiting to find out what he'd
see inside the mirror camera wingers in
an awesomely suspenseful shot and then
we find out how David Lynch decided to
handle the fact that Frank Silva had
passed and how he's going to show Bob we
see cuts of old footage to remind us
about Bob taking up residence in agent
Cooper's doppelganger after evil coupe
looks into the mirror one last time and
says you're still with me that's good to
me when I first watch it looked like
something happened with his face so I
brightened up the screen shot and it
clearly looks like we see Bob's image
overlaid just before the words are
spoken we go over to Twin Peaks and
catch up with Mike now that's Bobby's
high school buddy and later
naveen lover not the one-armed man and
he seems to be a responsible adult now
he rings out a character we don't know
about his crappy resume and then sends
him out of his office so it's a short
look but that's where Mike is that at
this point Sheriff Frank Truman is
talking to his brother Harry s on the
phone about his condition here I'm
talking about tests and whatever and you
know we know Harry is sick and that's
why they're not showing him Lucy comes
over the intercom to tell his wife is
coming and we get to meet Doris Doris
Truman Doris is dramatic in hyper which
is hilarious in contrast with how Frank
reacts like to everything she says she
basically yells at him a number you know
for all kinds of things and it just sits
there and listens patiently we see
dougie coupe in Janie II come out of the
house with sunny Jim she fixes his tie
and tells him that she's counted and
the money 425,000 in their secret place
and as she's telling him to make sure he
called them at work to arrange to pay
back their 50 grand he looks at sunny
Jim who's kind of sitting there standing
in space and a tear streamed out of
space she acknowledges finally that he's
acting weird as [ __ ] realizes his car
isn't there and then tells him she'll
take him to work back at Rancho Rosa we
see that the hired guns are looking at
Dougie's car and scoping out the house
basically they take off and we watch as
the camera spins around the other way
stopping briefly on the house where one
1-9 girl was and then we see a second
car pool of guys approach you don't
learn anything about them at this time
but they're you know they're in a custom
black muscle car and the music that
playing gives us an idea that they might
be you know some kind of level up from
the first two assassins we had met Jamie
II hurting my test to shove dougie coupe
out of the car towards his office in
order to get him to go she mentions that
he's having one of his episodes and I
wasn't sure if she meant like he's been
having in the last 24 hours
or is the original dougie prone to doing
some weird [ __ ] as well anyways he
shuffles towards the building stopping
and a statue of a man holding a gun
dougie coupe in his ill-fitting suit and
tie that his wife was right she can't
really get right ever and you know he
just stands there and sort of copies the
pose with his finger pointed like a gun
possibly remembering something about who
he is he is up standing still in the
lobby until someone approaches him
carrying a tray or two of coffee he says
often Dreamland again hon dougie and
tells him they have to hurry there's a
staff meeting and it starts in three
minutes I have to save the count
McLaughlin nailed this scene I almost
lost it watching how dougie Cooper looks
at you know how he looked as he's drawn
to the coffee and then he just sort of
follows after it it's seriously
priceless just a really funny scene and
really well act the next part though in
the elevator had
literally laughing out loud is dougie -
turns into what you could call a copy
zombie more or less after getting some
in his mouth after Spain the cup around
to find the hole
he immediately perks up prompting the
guy who was king that you know the
copies say damn good Joe which he
repeats again and then this is still
funny every time I watch it but they
finally get dougie assured into the
meeting room after he freaks out a
client by just sort of lurking there and
looking at him and inside we see his
co-workers who are all I may have to
mention that they were all dressed
pretty normally as compared to two
Dougie's attire we learned that he's an
insurance agent we meet a guy named Tony
who grabs him up in a playful headlock
and then whispers into dougie coops ear
that he covered him and you know for
that he owes him big time after a bit of
awkward standing around they get the
meeting started and Tony is talking
about a claim he says is legit but then
dougie sees this green light flash on
his face and just blurt out that he's
lying this doesn't go over well and you
know it's kind of interesting that I
mean it's similar to what he saw in the
casino with the little floating images
above the machines that were going to
hit but it's kind of interesting that it
happened with this guy in this place we
don't really know anything else about it
and it just sort of moves on anyways his
boss calls him into the office we're
done you can't explain anything let
alone anything related to why he called
Tony a liar he does key in on the word
agent and the word game in the normal
way that we get used to we're gonna use
- dougie - repeating things this annoys
the boss who gives him a stack of files
to look over as homework but he before
you let him go he warns him that how he
does with these files will have a whole
hell of a lot to do with his future with
this company Dougie cube just says Case
Files and then we move on when we see
him he is in the hall having a bathroom
emergency doing this little kid dance on
his brush and a new female character
comes along and asked
the men's room is lost and she offers to
sneak him into the women's room she
seems to be sweet on dougie coupe though
we don't know if they have a history or
not and his mind is basically only on
going to the bath back at the silver
Mustang Ranch we meet two new guys who
could be best described as wise guys
they are happy with the casino manager
at all for paying w-2 and proceeded to
beat him down in front of the three
disinterested showgirls that they
brought with them this one hundred
percent clear who they are or if one of
them is in charge of the other but Jim
Belushi's character fires the casino
manager and tells him to leave town he
promotes the other guy we met you know
whenever we run the casino with dougie
coop the last time and tells him to call
them if dougie coop ever enters the
casino again so now dougie coop has some
other people who are interested in who
he is and what he's up to at Rancho Rosa
we catch up with the Tweaker who is now
passed out and her son who is still
curious about Dougie's car across the
street he sneaks out of the house to
check out what the guy that he saw put
under underneath it but before he can
grab it the new crew of guys in the
black muscle car pull up and chase him
off they proceed to break into the car
which turns out to set off the explosive
device
the first group had placed there the kid
watches these three guys die and they
basically burn to death after being
blown up and you know the other two guys
that were with him take the car and go
you only guess that this didn't affect
his mother who was completely oblivious
as to what happened right outside her
house as we see her wake up after he you
know closes the door after running back
inside the explosion was cool and it was
a bit unexpected I guess for me at the
time and I'm really not sure where these
guys that these guys were just car
thieves or if that's a different thing
that's gonna happen now we catch up with
Jade next she's getting her Jeep
detailed the guy who's cleaning it gives
her coupes key from the Great Northern
which he found when he was cleaning the
car Jade looks at the
of it has one of those you know
addresses where you can mail it back
they used to have those on old hotel
keys so she takes it and drops it in the
mailbox that's nearby from there boom
we're back at the Double R we see Norma
sitting at a table working and watching
the counter Becky who we figure is
Shelley's daughter I think she mentioned
that it was that she had a daughter
Becky
in the first episode comes in and hits
her up for money when she leaves we see
that she's with the guy that Mike had
thrown out of his office earlier for
having a crappy resume and Norma pulls
up Shelley and after why she's giving
her money again it was like three times
in one week the kids move the car
because they realized Norma and Shelley
are watching and then they go and talk
in a place that out of the way you know
and you could tell right away that this
guy is strung out on drugs at first like
he doesn't seem happy with him but then
he gives her a taste and she you know
she doesn't look like it's the first
time she tried it she's obviously been
using drugs with him however she doesn't
look all screwed up like he does they
drive off and we see her blasted looking
at the sky and realized there are some
definite similarities between her and
Laura Almer it's actually a lovely scene
with I love how you love me playing in
the background as she's staring at the
sky blissfully through the t-tops of an
old Firebird it's just an instant
classic really his office dougie coupe
still has his files in hand and he has a
moment where he holds everybody up from
getting out of the elevator eventually
makes it outside and post stuff staring
at the statue again at the Twin Peaks
Sheriff's Department we find Annie and
Hawk in the conference room they're
flipping through documents and Andy s if
Hawks found any Indians because Andy
can't find any Indians of Potts just
basically answers no and that's all we
get between those two guys so after that
we catch up what dr. aunt or the guy we
used to call dr. Lawrence Jacobi in the
secret history you learned that the
state of Washington had revoked his
license to practice medicine so now we
find out what he does
and we you know he goes by dr. amp and
that he appears to host you know v-log
where he advocates for people to dig
themselves out of the [ __ ] and into the
truth he Hawks with those golden shovels
we saw him making two coats guaranteed
to help his viewers do that and all for
the fair price of $29.99
I can't detail everything he said but it
basically boils down to the powers that
be you're screwing everyone in
everything as he talks we see that Jerry
Horne and maybe Hurley are dedicated
fans we also find out that he's
broadcasting his show from white tail
heat we head over to the Pentagon which
is a brand new location for the show
there we meet Colonel Davis and Cindy
Cindy informs the colonel that they have
had another data base hit for major
garland Briggs's fingerprints this time
in Buckhorn South Dakota they mentioned
this is the 16th tape they've had for
his prints over the past 25 years and
the colonel says that it's probably not
real but sends her to South Dakota to
look into it he stresses before she goes
that if it is real then they have to
contact the FBI we go inside the
Roadhouse and meet a new character who's
smoking in a non-smoking booth and
you're so cool he can't be bothered to
ash in the ashtray that's sitting right
in front of him we see him pass money in
a cigarette pack which obviously looks
like a drug-related transaction and then
a girl at the next table asked him for a
light and he invites her to sit down he
grabs her up pretty aggressively after
she sits there and while he's holding
her he asked if she wants to [ __ ] and
then says that her and her friends are
like smoking babies that make him laugh
so this guy is obviously a bad boy type
but we don't find out any anything much
more about that a kind of sociopathic
but that's about it
in her office we find agent Tammy
Preston looking over Coop's files
comparing his photos those old and new
and his prints we can't tell what she's
looking for or if she's found anything
but we you know we just get the
impression that she's looking into any
and looking for any anomalies
and the two coops evil coupe is in a
room and has brought a phone by the
warden to make his one phone call like
Gordon Cole instructed he waits for the
water to go upstairs and then starts
talking to them to them the people he
can't see through the surveillance
cameras he says now that everyone's here
I will make my phone call and he sort of
you know trolls him a little bit he says
who should I call mr. strawberry no I
don't think he's taking any calls
eventually he says he knows who to call
and punch his numbers into the phone and
this causes the person you know like the
prison systems to malfunction and a
bunch of alarms to go up as all this
chaos is going on
he says the cow jumped over the moon
into the phone hangs it up and then
everything goes back to normal and all
those all the alarms shut off that takes
us to - Aires Argentina which we've
never been and we're only there briefly
but we see that's where the electronic
device from the very beginning that was
in the wooden bowl is located we see the
lights on it flash and then it does
something that's a little hard to
explain it sort of compresses itself
into a black small object like it sort
of implodes or yeah I don't know it
basically shrinks up into a little piece
of nothing we get one more shot of
dougie after that dougie coupe I should
say and he's still hanging out the
statue and as the security guard tells
him he needs to move on the episode ends
so really just a ton of stuff happened
in this episode it was so much fun the
wallet it was hilarious and parts it was
dreamy in parts and yeah I really liked
it if you skip through the recap welcome
to the video the recap took a long time
because let's face it a lot of stuff was
jam-packed inside this episode but now
I'm going to talk about the questions
that come up what do we know what do we
need to talk about between now and next
episode and remember I'll be doing a Q&A
later on the week probably on Thursday
or Friday so leave all of your questions
and can
in the comments related to anything
that's happened so far but this episode
in particular so the first big thing was
that you know the ring the ring that's
inside well it turns out to at the time
we don't know it's major Briggs for sure
that's been a popular theory and really
at the end we don't know either but we
know there's a good chance and we find
out the Dougie's ring is in his stomach
now I'm no expert on magic or cultism
but I do remember reading about Jack
Parsons in the secret history and
different rituals and things so but not
to look into that this week and see what
I can find out but I feel like this is
some sort of ritualistic thing you know
where evil coupe used that ring to
create Dougie dougie COO now the woman
in the office I really don't know much
about her she's obviously a go-between
between evil coupe and the assassins but
pretty much still mystery at this point
it was exciting to see Bob show up and
see how they decided to deal with that
we do know that he's still there I don't
think for me was ever a question if he
was still there as in a part of what we
know now as evil coupe the doppelganger
I wasn't sure if it worked the same as
it does with Leland and I'm still not
but you know that it was sort of a nice
reveal in that it shows that you know we
don't have to wear it wondering whether
Bob is there or not he definitely is
dougie dougie dougie dougie was pretty
hilarious in this episode did we find
out more about him well we know he has a
power that we didn't know about we know
that he has some feelings as we saw when
he had a tear with sonny jim and we know
slightly more about his creation but
yeah not a whole lot we're gonna there's
a lot differences a lot to discover
about how dougie came into existence and
all of that all right you know one of
the big things here for me that I was
thinking about throughout the episode is
what is the Great Northern going to do
whenever that ki arise that's going to
set off a chain of events I would
imagine because they'll figure out that
that is qu
and they hadn't seen that key since he
disappeared wonder where it came from so
on and so forth she's in Vegas he's in
Vegas so that might tip some people to
his location
could also be how we get Audrey Horne
into the picture but we'll have to wait
and see on that so yeah Becky she really
reminded me of Laura in the sense that
she looked like a good girl looks like
she does what she's supposed to do she's
young attractive blonde but clearly has
a problem with drugs in the credits
she's her name is Rebecca Becky
Bennett so you know first I was thinking
it was Bobby and Shelley's kid but I'm
not sure what she came from Norman
Shelley's talk was interesting and it
stood out at the time I mean obviously
Norma was talking about Hank like you
know staying with someone too long or
whatever and I was wondering was Shelley
saying they were green that they both
knew about that tell us your if it was
Leo's she was talking about or Bobby but
I don't know that we can tell from what
we saw evil coupe in the phone was
pretty hilarious and it kind of took him
up a level as far as what kind of stuff
he can do but I don't really know what
happened there I mean obviously he used
to code and it seems like that had the
effect on the electronic device in
Buenos Aires but can't say for sure
anyways I'm pretty sure Dougie Cooper
will make it home at some point but he's
out there in the wild right now so whoa
no really what's going on with him dr.
Jacoby dr. amp that was a very kind of
interesting twist for his character I
mean he was quirky before obviously and
we learned about his book that he wrote
in the secret history but this is a
whole new thing and it was interesting
to see Nadine they're just sort of
staring lovely lovingly at the you know
screen this tough guy at the bar he is
you know an enigma at this point I I you
know there's all this possibility of
connection between him and Becky and the
other guy her boyfriend but we're going
to have to wait and see on that as well
so what did you guys think was the best
part about this episode as you like to
laughs or did you like the reveals
for me I you know I just really enjoyed
the whole episode I thought it was a lot
of fun it was you know a game of some
love you who are asking about where we
going back to Twin Peaks I think we got
back there somewhat I think to keep
going back to the Great Northern is
going to give us a step further and the
dougie stuff was good and evil coupe
stuff was interesting and mysterious and
now we have the Pentagon involved and
Tammy seems to be on the case and I
think she's going to keep moving that
floor but we didn't get any kind of
update on what Albert and Cole are up to
so let's hope we find out that in the
next episode either way leave questions
comments I'll do the Q&A later this week
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and like the video if
you thought it was cool check back
regularly because I've been putting out
a constant schedule of twin peaks'
videos so if you haven't seen them check
those out and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon